la situation aux zaï a bien sûr été
évoquée au cours des entretiens Valérie
giscar destin léopolde SEDAR sangor le
président du Sénégal était en effet en
visite officielle en France le président
sangor a confié à Antenne 2 ses
préoccupations sur les conflits
africains je dois dire que la lutte
comme vous le savez c'est entre l'Est et
l'Ouest euh nous les
Africains nous sommes des moyens dans
l'affaire je
pense que l'Afrique doit se défendre
contre toute agression venue de
l'extérieur le voilà notre attitude à
nous Sénégal et si un État agressé de
l'extérieur nous demande notre
assistance nous répondrons favorablement
pourquoi affirmez-vous sans cè est-ce
que l'Occident prépare sa défaite en
Afrique parce que l'Occident qui nous a
appris à penser
rationnellement s'il pense
rationnellement n'agit pas
rationnellement par contre l'EST agit
rationnellement ils savent comme le
disait Lénine que qui tient l'Afrique
tient l'Europe ils ont les objectifs
précis et ils et il et ils mettent à
leur disposition des moyens
ultraamodernes efficaces tandis qu'
Occident la superpuissance américaine
menace en parole et la plupart des États
de l'Occident font état de leurs état
d'âme ce qui n'est pas
efficace